in Brooklyn now and then we walk through
this door and we're in the Upper West
Side of Manhattan that's right this is
the set welcome to my humble abode I
have apartment Envy so do I honestly we
were all fighting over who might get to
buy the real apartment on 113th and
Riverside yeah Tony is the only one who
can afford it
you actually got mail I do have some
mail and I bet honestly with the level
of detail on this set I bet there's real
I'm gonna they're gonna kill me but hold
on I thought there's real stuff inside I
was amazed there was actually a stamp
and it's type written oh yeah that's
Steve
oh yeah
this is a uh
Township and County tax oh God this is
going to be depressing
114 dollars and seven cents that's
expensive for back then yeah look at
that time this is time travel yeah